hey everyone Sam Gorski here director of
Avatar 2.
not that I have a tattoo we're talking
about the one that came out before the
true inspiration for Avatar 2. I don't
think I've ever seen anything like that
James if you're watching this whether
you're in a sub or at a resort I found a
little problem with your films first off
they're taking a long time to make but
second of all they're spending a lot of
money what if I told you there was a
free alternative yes that's right a free
alternative to swimming in the water and
getting your emotion capture not to
mention recreating your characters and
rendering them out too that's right it's
2023 the game is changing VFX is
changing and well with the GoPro a
swimming pool and your favorite pair of
spandex we can make Avatar 3 together
let me show you how we're gonna do it
[Music]
we're going to do some underwater motion
capture and show the world just how easy
it can be motion capture is now just
footage there's Rococo video now we
don't need a suit to do mocap anymore
you've probably seen all that stuff
right it's really cool it's free first
first off yeah sorry free which is crazy
and then you only need one video file
and it will basically analyze your data
your footage and give you a 3D skeleton
it doesn't require 10 years it doesn't
require a billion dollars doesn't
require a tier actors in fact they don't
know it yet Clint and Peter will reprise
their role but before we start
production we have to test the tech so I
filmed some tests in a pool I didn't
want to do this but
oh my gosh it's so bright
take a look so here I am swimming
swimming guy thumbs up I for some reason
I instinctually do the thumbs up almost
every time for some reason I don't know
what's going on so I'm not a stranger to
using AI tools and models to discern a
posture in fact we're doing a lot of
that for anime rock paper scissors too
that being said before I went into this
pool I mean I wasn't going in blind
there are best practices and here's what
they are
first off you're definitely gonna want a
wide shot you want to see the hands you
want to see the feet you want to see the
head you want to make sure you see that
whole body second of all you want a
clean silhouette that means your
background isn't going to add noise we
don't want it to be cluttered think
about filming on a green screen third of
all what you're wearing is going to be
very important so you want to make sure
you're wearing something that just helps
your body's form stick out also as a
bonus different colored tops and bottoms
will help segment your body and allow it
to understand what body part is what
just a little bit better right off the
bat I'm going to process this and so go
to Rococo video select my files
literally just drag it in basically it
uploads it it processes it and then I
can actually view the file in the Rococo
studio app all right sponsor time
because this video is actually sponsored
by Rococo Rococo video it's totally free
to use and it will always be currently
this is the easiest motion capture
software I have ever used all you need
to do is set up one camera it can be a
GoPro your phone all you're going to do
is you just frame up your whole body and
try and get the best motion possible and
from there he just process it it takes a
minute or two it's really fast and then
through Rococo Studio the app you can do
a little bit of cleanup here some tweaks
and Export it to whatever you want in
case Rococo video isn't enough and you
need real-time full body tracking
obviously they have their whole suits
and gloves and face capture system all
on their app which is really cool over
the last few months there's been a ton
of updates that have improved the
real-time tracking quality and even
though they don't want me to say this
they also have this incredible thing
called the coil that eliminates drift
that's huge you should take a look at it
it's pretty sweet so this is the first
underwater footage that I we have filmed
that I am processing seriously I'm
really hoping this works because we got
a whole video ahead of us still
underwater shot oh one here we go all
right
cross my fingers so hard they crack all
right three two one
[Music]
I see like a little bit of a glitchy leg
there but nothing you can't fix actually
and look I know what I'm getting into
here I know that this stuff is not
designed for underwater use it's not
designed for floating people but it's a
great opportunity to really push this
stuff and bring it into situations
people are not normally thinking about
and again I got to thank the guys at
Rococo for believing in this vision for
Avatar 3. thank you for letting me break
your product and post it on the internet
there's a little bit of cleanup but I
would actually say this is a success
next though we're gonna need a script
and there's only one way we're gonna
write it everyone's undergone a lot of
improvements since the last one I
learned how to do like character
animation and in the meantime Paul is
like AI text software well it got a
whole lot better too it's time to let my
old friend GPT do the heavy lifting here
as you see here I have a collaborative
prompt your goal is to write a one-page
script for an underwater mystical scene
in Avatar 3 between two nubby aliens and
then I'm having it basically stop and we
can tweak and approve stuff let's do
this ftar three the last one was in the
water a lot so I'm imagining if this is
like the intro for the third movie it's
a scene maybe where they're in the water
and then we introduce fire and it's kind
of like the Sizzler the scene takes
place with a magnificent underwater cave
bioluminescent plants love it carry
voice filled with water no kidding do
you feel the presence of AWA this energy
surrounds us guiding our every move you
gotta hook the audiences with some crazy
voice over they Theory I have heard
Whispers of a new threat lurking in the
depths we must prepare It's Quickly
sending into like babies first like
monster story yeah well I said make sure
you give this monster storyline a wild
twist but natiri what if this creature
is no ordinary Beast what if it
possesses the power to control the very
currents that's around us oh that's very
Avatar
um I'm already gonna say this right now
we know it's fire so this monster is
clearly related to the lava we're nearly
there just a little more and then we let
the fire do its work
this feels like I'm three what
do you think look AI can't take us 100
of the way there sometimes a human needs
to step and do the heavy lifting we got
Stakes we got comedy we have playful
jump scares we have the threat of the
entire ocean boiling which honestly the
more I think about it I'm like that that
could be it that's a World building line
right there this script is Rock Solid I
have a total grasp on everything now
with animation one thing left to do is
hold our breath
Clint and Peter they're gonna reprise
their roles here we are going into this
pool my promise to you is that today we
were only gonna shoot this once we're
not gonna do four reshoots after this
the first time was like that was fun
second time's like all right now we're
working I have a permanent dent in my
head
so tight so I in this bag I have our
high-tech motion capture suits
[Music]
I've I've never actually directed a film
outside my natural habitat like it's no
underwater stuff I mean the pressure's
on
[Music]
so the shoe went really well we got
everything we needed Clinton Peter were
able to stay underwater long enough we
got many really long takes so Jimmy if
you're still watching this video don't
shut it off yet because what I'm about
to show you well it's gonna blow your
mind let's take a look at this shot of
Clint's very interesting dolphin
both feet frequently visible both hands
frequently visible check this out this
one is pretty good
[Laughter]
it's pretty smooth it's smooth and once
again what's so weird about it is like
okay you can't see the other hand for a
large part of it yet it knows to like
put the hand on the other side of the
body I'm pretty pretty amps because the
amount of cleanup I have to do is almost
non-existent now nice this is way better
than everything else we are doing it
it's all working pretty neat can't wait
to see it animated and Unreal Engine
this will take a few days it's complete
and compared to James Cameron that's
light years ahead so I think we got a
good picture
so we have all the underwater
performance captured but that still
leaves us with the facial performance
the processes we're going to actually be
using the brand new Madea human animator
we have all that face cap data now it's
really fast to actually get this stuff
to work and I can't wait to show you
these results so in order for it to work
it needs to basically have a model of
you know it needs to know what your face
looks like in 3D so neutral pose here
that's front view so let's automatically
tracks through that part and then it's
gonna refine it in a minute
so there's your head now we can actually
just take the footage and start
animating this all right prepare for
performance preparing for performance a
little bit more and we'll let the steam
scare it off
oh my God you're not used to seeing that
with the phone right no last time we did
this it was about a like a week and a
half to two weeks of Us coming back back
and forth trying again trying and trying
again now it's like a couple days you
got all the technical stuff in the can
now it's now it's where the Artistry
comes in and you gotta like make it look
nice with all the underwater stuff yeah
get to some good angles and stuff
basically we have to put it all together
now we're finally at that intersection
where I gotta start making this thing so
there's a few things I'm juggling right
now I got made of human data so I have
to make Avatar made of humans there's no
way you can create this character if
you're doing it manually in the made a
human Creator but if you feed it a
custom mesh which we have
we can start to get those alien
proportions wait a second they're not
blue
I'll make them blue I'll just I'm just
just get a tintum blue I'm going to
leave the Tails and all the clothes to
the very end that's fluff I'm here for
the performance in the emotion capture I
also need an awesome environment so we
have to source that for the environment
oh man this is incredible how far I'm
able to get with using only free
software my environment is also free
Kareem abashusa has posted the unreal
five underwater blueprint I saw one
screenshot of this and I knew it was
going to be the set of my next feature
film welcome to the oceans of Pandora
[Music]
wow yeah it's so vibrant and beautiful I
love those bubbs I have to drop the
characters into the scene I'm going to
start with their body motion capture I
put the synced facial capture data onto
those takes as well there he is floating
in the water just like an avatar and
they're not blue and they're wearing
underwear still is there any animation
cleanup to do yeah look at that arm is
clipping through him control rig we'll
fix all that remember we're pushing this
Rococo video software to the edge of its
limits and the fact that it's working
this well is super impressive and I can
already tell that my vision is beginning
to come alive I have nothing left to do
here but try and sync up all these takes
get blocking done build these Shots Out
build this story out here and render it
out for your viewing pleasure I think
James Cameron's gonna have to clear his
schedule a little early that Premiere is
coming soon
the red carpet together
[Music]
it's crazy meaning the actors in person
because it reminds you they're just
people too
thanks for coming here this big deal for
me and James Cameron
you know obviously Clint Peter thanks
for coming back for the third one and
the second one was a big deal is also
was a disaster but it means a lot that
he came back it's an honor
there is like almost no cleanup going on
here all I'm doing here some eye line
correction okay and then uh you know
just some like arm width correction to
make sure you're not clipping through
yourself you know I think it's important
to like get a good sense of how these
tools actually function so imagine 20th
Century Fox logo
we're cutting that for copyright reasons
is ready
[Music]
toucan never cease with your games
are we prepared ever ready for fun and
the dangerous too meteria
we must lead it to the firewalls but
remember it's a double-edged sword one
wrong move could boil our world I know
I not heard carefully
a little bit more a little bit more
we'll let the steam scare It Off
and don't boil our world
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the fireworks they're our protector and
our potential Doom
[Music]
[Applause]
that was fantastic that was some Cinema
level filmmaking right there I look
great was it just you or do you have
some like backup on it I mean James
Cameron obviously was integral but uh
you know from like more of the
engineering and Technical you know BTS
aspect is all me I look good shaders on
the skin the way the body's moved and
everything is pretty crazy there were a
couple moments where I saw a little bit
of Jank you know some like some arms
skipping but for the most part it was
pretty dang good I was very impressed so
yeah that's a wrap on Avatar three and
uh
listen
[Music]
[Applause]